understanding proofs includes the
ability to spot mistakes in them and as
a test of that skill and also your
understanding of induction let me see if
I can put one over on you I'm gonna show
you a bogus proof by induction and I'm
gonna prove something that's patently
absurd namely that all horses have the
same color say they're all black so
there's a bunch of black horses with
maybe some highlighted Brown Mane's
all right I'm gonna prove this by
induction and for a start
there's no end mentioned in the theorem
so that's common for various kinds of
things that you need to prove by
induction so I have to rephrase it in
terms of n it's gonna be by induction on
n the induction hypothesis is gonna be
that any set consisting of exactly n
horses will all have the same color all
right
let's proceed to prove this now I'm
going to use the base case N equals 1
just because I don't want to distract
you with suspicions that the base case N
equals zero that is know horses is
cheating somehow the B in fact be
perfectly legitimate to start with N
equals zero and argue that all the
horses in the empty set have the same
color because there's nothing in the
empty set however let's not get into
that well we'll start with N equals 1
and indeed if you look at any set of 1
horse it is the same color of its as
itself and in fact I've proved the base
case N equals 1 all right let's keep
going now in the inductive step I'm
allowed to assume that n horses have the
same color where n is any number greater
than or equal to 0
now right here students complain that
that's not fair because you're already
assuming something false and that's
absurd well yeah it is absurd but that
can't be the problem I'm just allowed to
assume an induction hypothesis all I
have to do is prove that and implies n
plus 1 since it's absurd there would it
be some problem with the proof well
let's watch and say if there's a problem
with the proof so again I
assume that any set of n horses have the
same color I have to prove that any set
of n plus 1 horses have the same color
how will I do that well there's a set of
n plus 1 horses and let's consider the
first n of those horses now by induction
hypothesis the first end of them have
the same color black maybe ok
well so by induction hypothesis the
second set of n horses that is all but
the first horse have the same color yeah
and what that tells me is that the first
and the last horse have the same color
as all of the horses in the middle and
therefore in fact they all have the same
color end of proof QED
all right so there better be something
wrong and what's wrong well what's wrong
is that the proof that P of n implies P
of n plus 1 is wrong it looked good but
the proof that P of n implies P of n
plus 1 has to work for all N greater
than or equal to the base case and if
you look at this proof it doesn't work
in in the base case when n is 1 and
you're trying to go from the base case
to 2 and so on by implication the proof
breaks down because what happens with
our argument in the case that we're
trying to prove that p of n implies P of
n plus 1 in the case that N equals 1
well in that case there aren't any
middle horses n plus 1 is 2 so there's a
first horse and that's the first n
horses and then the second had a set of
n horses is the other horse and there
are no middle horses that they both have
a color in common with so the proof just
broke there but you might not have
noticed because that was the only place
that was broken this is a case where we
were misled by ellipses by the way where
because I was drawing n plus 1 horses
with Allah showing a lot of horses with
dots in the middle it looked like there
were some but there weren't and
again the boys I said the point though
is that the only fallacy in this proof
was that it didn't work when n was 1 but
it certainly worked and for implying
that if all sets of two horses are the
same that does imply that all sets of
three horses are the same color and
again it's a false will imply anything a
kind of example but even here the the
proof was logically ok but if it breaks
at one place if there's one Domino
that's missing from the line when the
one before it falls the rest of them
stop falling and the proof breaks down